ça alors c'est trop peu non mais quel
toupet ce casimir et c'est léonard nous
faire ça à nous bon je n'en reviens pas
alors mes bons amis que se passe-t-il
vous semblez étonné
étonné membres avaient mille apprenez à
dire le terme est vague correspondant à
chaque situation pardon monsieur du snob
mais françois junior l'air étonné mais
ils sont catastrophés médusé annihiler
mais monsieur du sns a parfaitement
raison nous sommes littéralement
estomaqué
il y a de quoi meilleur ami qu'est le
trouble affreux qui vient planer au
dessus de vos esprits égarés
soi explique lui moi c'est tout de suite
mes forces et bien voilà monsieur du
snob et vos facteurs nous venons
d'apercevoir casimir et leonard ce
dirigeant furtivement vers le petit bois
avec des paniers remplis pour faire un
bon pique nique je vois ils ne nous ont
pas inviter à leur festin sylvestre
quand ils nous ont vus ils ont fait un
détour pour ne pas nous rencontrer à
faire ripaille c'est à dire faire un bon
repas ça leur compagnon de toujours on
aura tout vu pour sûr moi cette histoire
de pique nique ça me donne font
[Rires]
écouter mes amis ça me donne une idée
nous allons nous rendre chez casimir et
là bas nous on veut faire un bon petit
repas fin
je suis quand même une compagne j'ai
fait j'ai pris un petit papier je vais
tout noté je m'occupais des courses 1 ça
serait bien alors qu'elle mourier vous
manger à leurs valeurs
bancaires
paris mme shalev
des grilles
je crois vous avoir compris faites moi
confiance
ce sera bien
[Musique]
là
là alors c'est bientôt prêt à attendait
une petite minute encore mademoiselle
julie chantera deux terminé de dresser
le couvert à très bien c'est une idée
très drôle de la voir installer si on
l'a mal des léonards que pensez vous mon
cher françois
la qualité artistique du menu que je
viens de peindre or il ya un peu trop de
fioritures annuler y est c'est du sable
à la non mais c'est quand même ravissant
avec un très brave garçon françois aubin
j'espère que vous ne redoutez pas
mentionneraient
et vient voilà mes amis tout est prêt
ouais voilà
merci
voilà
ce
service est très gentil à vous de
m'avoir interdit de faire quelque chose
ça lui faisait plaisir veux-tu entendre
le menu gilles amiot des pères et frères
salade de printemps printemps
d'empreintes en vente au
poulet rôti
[Musique]
oui divin
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant à table messieurs entendu
et bien nous avons tous
et bien attaquer
c'est que jamais au moment de manger je
n'ai plus très fin
ça fait exactement la même impression
j'ai l'impression qu'il manque quelque
chose à notre repas pour qu'il soit
parfait ah ben oui oui le fromage csii
il manque les fromages voyons mon cher
et 1000 francs soit élu ne faisait pas
allusion au fromage mais à l'absence de
casimir de léonard
vous ne trouvez pas facteur que notre
repas ressemble au repas de famille où
il manquerait un frère ou un cousin très
proche du tout je vous en prie françois
soyons sérieux vous le savez casimir et
léonard nous ont joué un sale tour bon
n'avons pas nous gêner bourg très bien d
emile n'ayant cadre à bord bonjour
mais qu'est ce que vous faites vous vous
prenez un repas chez moi et vous n'avez
même pas invité mais enfin quasi mur tu
étais en train de manger tranquillement
avec léonard bon vous êtes vraiment trop
pas justin nous avons juste faire en
tout petit goûter j'ai encore faim moi
allez cabinet assieds toi avec nous et
mange
rihanna tu peux sortir nous sommes
invités
au leona
[Musique]